ma non è che stagna mettiamo dell'uva
come reagirà unità secondo voi ciao
ragazzi ho comprato tutti questi
calendari dell'avvento di cibo sembrano
super interessanti quella teca grande e
questo pesa tantissimo
non vedo l'ora di aprirli e mangiarli
tutti ci sono un problema e vitale libet
e gli porrà mangiare letteralmente tutti
nasconderò qua nella camera e voi vi
lascerò qua a controllare la stanza così
potrete avvisarmi 6 vitale entrato e ha
mangiato qualcosa berlino tu non fare la
spia e vive dove li ho nascosti
altrimenti evitare l'immagine a tutti
quindi vi raccomandano di lynette è ok
affare fatto fare patto però vi faccio
vedere dove ho nascosto i calendari così
potrete sorvegliare meglio la stanza
uno è un altro e non lo trovo neanche io
bene vuol dire che l'ho nascosto bene
comunque quest'opera è uno sopra ed è
verde quindi si mimetizza con il verde
che dietro fatto a letto voi lasciate un
bel mi piace mi raccomando se volete
vedere altri salangi di cibo se questo
video raggiunge i 20 mila mi piace
faremo un'altra salese di cibo
consigliate ce l'ha pure nei commenti se
non mi seguite ancora su instagram
andate a seguirmi il nome alita stories
se volete seguitemi anche su tik tok 92
previte stories ora iniziamo subito una
challenge
sento odore di cibo che cosa hai fatto
per l'eroe nascosto del cibo qua dentro
cos'è questo se di caramelle oggi è
stato il mio giorno fortunato l'appoggia
qui e le mangiano tutte dopo qualcuno
qui ha nascosto del cioccolato caffè 3
maggio tutte tutte tutte allora berlino
io lo appoggio qui torno dire niente
facciamo un patto
io mi metto qui mangio tutto e dopo ti
porta a fare la passeggiata va bene ok
avrei fatto che cos'è questo pop corn
wow bene pronta la sessione di
degustazione
mettiamoci comodi vediamo che cosa
abbiamo qui degustare insieme a
chiediamo vogliamo al numero apriamo
numeroso apriamo così si o no
sale aceto ma sono quelle che a me non
piacciono
ravenna fa niente le manderò comunque
sto ammirando la mia bellissima
collezione di libri ho sentito un rumore
strano meglio andare a controllare
[Applauso]
facendo tutti e due
il bambino mette a sedere a primo questa
cosa merlino tela schietta ora non ci
credo berlino aveva fatto un patto con
me che riteneva tutti i nas cosino
trovato in altri no la missione scritti
sul tavolo del mercato fine è adesso
seri sequestro tutti cosa stanno questi
con buonissimi e stato eletto in
consiglio anche questo è il cioccolato
corno caramellati buonissimi ho fatto
bene o no no no ma è un fatto che si
impossibile avevo nascosto tutti questi
calendari per fare la challenge in cui
mangiavamo il cibo del calendario degli
eventi per 24 ore maturi stai già
finendo e qual è il problema cia lancia
iniziata ok allora iniziata tu hai già
fatto colazione pranzo mamma mamma the
tutte e due devo mangiare io e il pranzo
ma che vi fidiate tutto lascia lo lascia
la dove lo stai portando questo bisogna
come per montarlo no
pensi che non ti ho visto che ero maggio
un altro parco grazie ciao
guardate che disastro che ha fatto
vitale guardate ha lasciato solo queste
le caramelle sapete perché le ha
lasciate perché queste possono anche
avere dei sapori disgustosi possiamo
lavorare assieme un piano di un bello
scherzetto
prenderò uno di questi calendari close
vuoto lillo tempo con qualcos'altro così
avrà una bellissima sorpresina per me
rende vitale
vabbè io inizio ad aprirle che cosa
volete parlare lo aspetti ecco la sapeva
tutto la tele caramelle buonissimi il
mood food una merlino ti rompo e
mangiarli
e allora aspetta fammi controllare una
cosa cosa vuoi controllare questa
potrebbe essere pesca pesca io non ti
posso dire niente sentito perché lo
voglio io adoro la perini grazie fammi
sapere che sapore ha che sapore ha di
che cosa fa schifo schifo è andata male
per miss intimo e sapore fumi vediamo
che cos'altro abbiamo qua la mano
all'altra una buona
no non lo voglio se puzza non la voglio
radiocor berlino terrificanti la
caravella mera potrebbe essere o
liquirizia oppure puzzo la rai si
scoraggi questo potrebbe essere opera o
caccole by budget senza odorare vai che
cos'è vastissimo spesa con l'altro beffa
di caccole che schifo dai ora stato io
vediamo la moda non vedevi annusare che
puzza di assaggio dello stato
assaggiate due brutte ieri dalla regalo
giusto che volete solo a me adesso ne a
procuragli operativa bene veramente mi
capiteranno quelle buone
dov'è il numero due berlino sta ancora
sperando di mangiare la presenza di
partito lama prezzo mangiare e sono
tantissimo quelle due c'è una puzza
incredibile
eccola qui facciamo qualcosa di nuovo
vista
apriamo le prevediamo allora io la sento
bendata perché giri ben dalla di due
sapori può essere poi ok hai scelto
questa intanto non resisto quindi ne
prendo uno anch'io quello che ho preso
io coltivo po formaggio con la muffa che
è quella che ho preso io probabilmente
oppure pop corn al caramello forse poco
male in effetti
ecco qua ragazzi è un'altra di quelle
nere che potrebbe essere un liquidità o
puzzola non ci credo che fortuna che sta
bianca potrebbe essere o cocco oppure
latte andato a male che abbiamo ci
credono neanche una buona allora apriamo
l'ultimissimo perché poi li faremo
merenda e poi dobbiamo fare la frena
quindi non possiamo mandarli tutti a
vero che avremo l'ultima
sì abbiamo trovato tutti i frutti sono
due così una per me e uno per evitare
che tutti frutti potrebbe essere o tutti
i frutti appunto oppure calze buzzetti
[Musica]
ecco quale due tuttifrutti 1 e tutti i
frutti non è calcio puzzolenti quale sei
questa berlino come ti fanno piacere le
calze scrivi che sapore hanno queste
calze sudore quale scegli anche tu la
devi prendere certo la bruno 2 mai non
ci credo
allora per l'ultimo tv ruote ne
prenderemo una casa occhi chiusi senza
guardare il colore senza guardare che
cosa significa senza guardare niente o
per chi inizia l'inizio tu ok andiamo
che questa volta mi capiterà proprio
albero una buona
ecco quel colore bianco cocco e co.co.co
non ci credo non ci credo come fai
decine di imprese non dover guardare a
noi dobbiamo guardare
che cos'è
popcorn salado divorati è andata bene
che sarà nella commedia
quando ho preso un altro non so se
rischiare vero purtroppo dati di
rischiano che cos'è cose in pari a
prenderli 2 che cosa esso quello schifo
volo morto e papà ragazzi sto mangiando
ma nel frattempo sta anche preparando
blu scherzetto per vitale ora vi faccio
vedere
guardate un po ho preso un po di cose
sane come frutta la frutta secca coach e
merlino che sta cercando se c'è qualcosa
da mangiare e da rubare linea zero per
te queste cose ti sostituirò nelle
castellini con queste cose sane a
berlino marino non è per te il mandarino
una castagna ma il ministro ha detto mio
assistente come reagirà vitale secondo
voi mettiamo dell'uva qua dentro frutta
secca
lui si aspetterà i cioccolati le
caramelle ma invece no il momento della
cena che abbiamo subito contro questi
vitale pronta a cena libertador
tarallucci guarda quello che troviamo
nel calendario della
ovviamente che soprattutto ci sono miei
per farmelo censore uno valido lo faccio
assaggiare le pringles prima va bene
solo uno die scarta pure il calendario
permesso niente e allora potrebbe di
riaprirne un'altra ma non c'è niente
questi abbiamo aperti tutti prima
struttura castagna ma dobbiamo cuocere
di casi può mangiare così un altro
castagna nomina carmen e mi dispiace
sono finite visto che ne hai mangiato
troppo ma non c'è mi 82 castani andati a
cena vantaggio quello che fai
c'è qualcosa che si muova con dentro una
noce vengano 0 0 dai pari a rubarvi
calendari di notte rosa è una noce di
inserita la festa ma certo mica la butto
lì ho trovato un'altra cosa
l'altro noce mondovino abbiamo anche
dell'uva qui come solo la frutta secca
la brutta vera
ma non ti preoccupare perché c'è altro
un altro barberino e dai alla fine
altra brutta riportare la tua cena
qualcos'altro lo aspetta troppo qualcosa
qui ho trovato un'altra musica
allora mi basta cercare meglio una notte
con buona bene quindi se ho mangiato
relativa tantissimo a cena io devo
ancora aprire questo il succo la avevano
pero la cd località mandarino cioccolato
d'anna becca qualche cioccolatino
fondente
ecco quando mandarino naturale questo è
mio e lo scarpone vuoto mi devo dirti
una cosa che cosa non mi sento bene i
magi tutte quelle schifezze lì è normale
che questi malanni aver mangiato tutti
questi mesi mi ha un po di nota no
adesso ti mangia di tutto quelle
schifezze questo tema taglio di mettere
così male per sentirmi bene grazie ciao
6 4
non è possibile vitale è scappato via
della casa pur di rubare i calendari con
i dolci incorreggibile che prendo io
rientro dentro fa troppo dire colpevole
è tornato smettila di mangiare
lasciatemi piace se volete vedere altre
challenge di cibo vitale ne sarà molto
molto contento che pensavo colpa altre
case linee su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quelle
che preferite badate cioccolato sociale
da mangiare tanta frutta e verdura così
io che stavi farò bene bene non mi farà
la nausea alla ru da guido pasi dei
mandarini